tout de suite avec vous deviez de
douleur et aux vous êtes chercheur à
l'ifan à l'institut français d'analysé
stratégique chercheur associé à l'iris
et rédacteur en chef de la revue aurions
stratégique bonjour à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
ce nouveau cessez-le-feu en aghanistan
il est censé durer trois jours est ce
que vous pensez qu'elle va être
respectée oui je sais pas le il ya eu
des précédents il ya eu déjà pour le la
fête de l'aïd rang en juin 2018 était en
et en mai 2020 déjà il y avait eu
effectivement votre à jour de ces feux
mais c'est pas si c'est le feu qui est
structurelle il est conjoncturel lié
justement à la fête religieuse et on
peut noter d'ailleurs que il a été il a
été promu par l'étalement d'une certaine
manière c'est eux qui fixe le calendrier
de la cessation des hostilités actuelles
et non pas le gouvernement qui s'est
ralliée évidemment à cette initiative
mais en réalité c'est le calendrier est
fixé par les talibans alors dimanche
dernier un attentat contre une école de
filles à kaboul en attentat qui a fait
plus de 50 morts
elles les autorités l'an plutôt talibans
est le signe d'une grande offensive
talibane à venir surtout après à la fin
du retrait des soldats américains l'ont
fait pour hall 11 septembre
alors les talibans ont effectivement
laissé en tant qu'ils allaient profiter
du retrait américain pour pour encercler
les villes
qu'est ce que c'est l'enjeu principal
c'est celui là il ya une pression qui
monte qui a été d'ailleurs relevé par le
chef d'état major interarmées américain
bill et qui disait que la pression
militaire des talibans étaient attendus
pour autant la question de la défense
des villes et baitha le principal
problème parce que jusqu'à présent les
talibans lorsqu'ils disent arriver à
prendre une ville la paire d assez
rapidement des grâce à la reprise des
troupes du gouvernement avec le soutien
aérien américain là la différence aérien
va être évidemment va plus être les
mêmes
déliter qu'auparavant avec le retrait
des troupes de la coalition et et
concernant les attentats y en a eu
beaucoup aimé celui de effectivement de
kaboul a visé une fois de plus la
communauté hazara
les talibans ont nié être responsable
donc sous-entendu c'était pour
l'attribuer à l'été islamique en
afghanistan il ya une grande confusion
qui règne mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il risque d'y avoir une
multiplication de ces attentats au sein
des vides alors que depuis le 1er mai le
pays connaît une recrudescence des
violences les états unis devaient
d'ailleurs retiré à cette date
2500 soldats ils sont encore sur place à
ce que cela signifiait que washington
pourrait avoir l'intention de repousser
le calendrier de retrait justement à
cause de la situation sécuritaire
il ya déjà eu une modification puisque
les américains avaient repoussé
officiellement ou 11 11 septembre 2021
le retrait total de leurs troupes
puis un peu plus de 3000 qui reste sans
parler des troupes de la coalition
notamment des allemands des tubes des
britanniques italiens et en l'occurrence
ils sont revenus à nouveau sur le
calendrier en parlons plutôt du 4
juillet jour de la fête nationale
américaine d'ailleurs c'était une
manière de parce que les talibans
avaient refusé de participer à la
conférence en turquie conférence de
négociations pour la transition pour la
paix et au motif que les américains
n'avaient pas respecté la date du
premier du 1er mai qui était inhérente à
l'accord passé à doigts entre talibans
et américains donc il ya il ya des
modifications de calendrier c'est aussi
vraisemblablement pour pousser les
talibans à revenir dans le jeu
négociations donc de ne plus parler de
la date du 11 septembre de l'avancé au 4
juillet mais c'est aussi le signe d'une
grande fébrilité de part et d'autre
parce que on sent bien qu'on est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un changement de
paradigme
alors juste pour que l'on comprenne bien
en fait la situation qu'elle est
aujourd'hui l'influencent la force des
talibans dans le pays puisque ce sont
eux qui ont décrété le cessez-le-feu
la majorité du pays notamment les zones
rurales seront frais
je mens sous contrôle total ou partiel
des talibans à l'exception des gares et
des grandes villes des districts mais la
question va être posée d'ailleurs elle a
été soulevée par les chefs américains
notamment le général mc quasi chef du
centcom américain qui a atteint selon la
commission des forces armées
le 22 avril dernier est considéré qu'il
était inquiet par la capacité
quant à la capacité des troupes de
l'armée afghane à pouvoir résister sans
le soutien aérien américain auquel il
était habitué jusque là et qu'on met
pour sa part marqué le chef d'état major
interarmes disait que dans la pire des
situations où risquent effectivement un
effondrement de l'armée afghane retour
de la guerre civile une catastrophe
humanitaire
c'est dire que les chefs américains sont
quand même très perplexe sur le devenir
de ce retrait et on peut noter un ancien
commandant le général petraeus qui
disait que dans une interview récente
qui a accordé des mines et que le
retrait américain ne mettra pas fin à la
guerre sans fin justement d'afghanistan
ça signifiera simplement le que les
états unis et les troupes de la
coalition ne seront plus impliqués
militairement mais en signalant qu'ils
avaient carrément une forte inquiétude
pour la suite des événements et que les
états unis pourraient regretter à
échéance de deux à trois ans à ce
retrait un peu précipité donc on a là le
syndrome le syndrome vietnamien et
rapidement il ya eu des négociations de
paix en fait tant contre les insurgés
talibans et le gouvernement afghan
des négociations qui sont au point mort
est ce qu'il ya une possible reprise ou
pas c'est le problème parce
qu'effectivement les talibans joue la
montre d'ailleurs il ya un proverbe qui
[Musique]
dit aux occidentaux vous avez la montre
et nous avons le temps parce que
le temps joue en leur faveur
concrètement ils savent que le départ
des troupes occidentales est actée et
que le gouvernement afghan va se
retrouver dans une situation difficile
même s'il considère qu' il ya les moyens
de pouvoir lutter contre contre
l'offensive des talibans
l'état l'immense o2 j'ai donc se
permettre éventuellement ne ne pas de ne
pas aller plus avant dans les
négociations pour montrer que c'est une
certaine manière qu'ils sont les maîtres
du jeu
merci beaucoup à vous david rigoulet
roze je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé à l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique